welcome to the man of Recaps this is
She-Hulk meet Jennifer Walters a nice
normal lawyer except that her cousin is
Bruce Banner The Incredible Hulk one day
they get in a car crash where some of
his blood gets into hers and because
she's got the gene the gamma blood turns
her into a Hulk but luckily unlike Bruce
who had to spend years learning to
control his rage Monster uh Jen doesn't
have a split personality in there she's
under control right away so her cousin
Bruce gives it the crash course on how
to be a Hulk and she picks it up real
quick and now Jen's like look I didn't
pass the bar to be a superhero I'm going
back to LA to be a lawyer but when a
super villain's on the loose Jen has to
transform to save the day and now
whether she likes it or not she is the
superhero She-Hulk having superpowers
gets her fired from her current job but
lands are a new better one because they
want a super person to head up their new
superhuman Law Department and her first
big case is the parole hearing for none
other than Amir Blonsky the Abomination
yes he's back from The Incredible Hulk
movie in 2008 a million years ago and he
makes a great point he wasn't really a
villain in that movie he was hired by by
the government to take the Hulk down
they pumped him full of experimental
Hulk drugs that made him into an
uncontrollable rage monster there is a
big problem though when the video
surfaces of him in chongqi fighting long
in the cage fight so at his parole
hearing they need to call Wong to the
stand who's like yeah sorry I broke him
out of jail but then we put him right
back that's definitely legal but Wong
isn't under U.S jurisdiction now blonski
proves that much like Bruce Banner he's
learned to control his rage monster too
and so with the condition that he's not
allowed to transform they did it he's
getting out on parole now Wonga comes
back because he needs a lawyer he wants
to Sue this wizard school dropout that's
using real magic in his act he sent the
hilarious party girl Madison to a demon
Dimension and yeah this hilarious
ridiculous legal misadventure is a good
example of the tone of this show now
Jen's dating life at the moment is kind
of sad so she decides to make a profile
as She-Hulk where she meets some real
hot guys but sadly they're not really
interested in sticking around for Jen
that hurts now the super villain she
fought in F1 is not really a villain
she's Titania the super influencer and
now she's suing Jen over the name
She-Hulk which Titania is using in her
new line of product adults she kind of
becomes she helps arch nemesis when they
had a wedding they end up duking it out
it's actually her dating profile as She
Hulk that wins the case but now her sad
love life is public record but soon
after she meets a really nice guy named
Josh and they hit it off things are
going great until one day he ghosts her
out of nowhere oof but now she goes to
check on Emil Blonsky who's become a
self-help Guru and this hilarious group
of Misfit super people convince her to
love herself part of that self-love is
getting some clothes you look good in so
she goes to see superhero Taylor Luke
Jacobson who agrees to make her a super
suit and some real suits but just then
she gets a new client that's suing him
yes it's the lame wannabe hero frog man
whose suit malfunctioned and guess who
Luke Jacobson's lawyer is yes it's
happening it's Matt Murdock Daredevil he
flew out from New York because he's a
client too and instantly he wins this
case afterwards he and Jen kind of hit
it off but that night she gets a call
from her clients being chased so she
goes down there and oh it's Daredevil
they have a little She-Hulk Vs Daredevil
fight oh yeah he looks awesome in the
end she wins and they talk it out turns
out Frogman kidnapped Luke to make him a
new suit so it's time for a classic
Daredevil hallway fight but Oh She Hulk
busts in there takes care of it much
quicker so Matt and Jen did some
lawyering together and some superheroing
together and now yes it's happening
these two get it on Daredevil who didn't
bring a change of clothes do in the
morning after Walk of Shame now the main
villain of the season are these internet
trolls who basically hate She-Hulk just
for being a woman in fact Josh was one
of them he was just playing her and now
they've hacked the thing playing the sex
tape he took so Jen is justifiably real
mad and hulk smashes this thing but the
government takes rampaging hulks very
seriously and now she's in big trouble
it's wildly unfair but that's how it is
and she gets the Blonsky deal her Hulk
powers are revoked so her friends go
undercover posing as one of the trolls
and get invited to an in-person Meetup
they discover the identity of their
ringleader Todd but turns out the
keynote speaker for this Meetup is none
other than the Abomination he's not one
of them though he doesn't even know what
this group is he's just hired as a
motivational speaker which still very
much violates is parole but now turns
out Todd stole some of her blood injects
himself gets Hulk powers then Titania
busts in then Bruce busts in and Jen's
like wait what is even happening here
she busts out an epic fourth wall break
hulk smashes herself straight to the
making of show to talk to the writer's
room she fights her way through Marvel
Studio security to talk to the big man
himself Kevin personified as an evil AI
bot and so she rewrites her finale like
look this is not what my show's about
she doesn't need a big Hulk fight she
can take down her villain with the legal
system Blonsky really is a redeemed good
guy but he violated his parole so he's
got to go back to jail but this time he
calls his friend Wong to pick him up
like yeah I think I'll live outside of
U.S jurisdiction Matt Murdoch comes over
to meet her family yeah these two are
really dating and her cousin Bruce
Banner who flew off to space well now
he's back with his Hulk son yeah this
world just keeps getting bigger and as
for Jen Walters she's now living the
She-Hulk dream lawyer and superhero and
that's where She-Hulk comes to an end
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]